OK.
This is an incredibly important in maintaining
an accurate understanding of this week's protests,
despite claims from Trump and his press secretary
and a ton of different right wingers.
That and TFA was doing all sorts of violence
in Washington, D.C. at the protests this week.
The FBI has found no evidence that and TFA
was involved in the Washington, D.C. violence
on Sunday.
That's the day that the protests sort of had
peak violence or unrest.
They've become more and more peaceful throughout
the week.
Now, the reason this matters is that one of
the ways that the Trump administration has
waged a propaganda war against the overwhelmingly
peaceful protesters is by making them seem
co-opted by and TFA an overwhelmingly violent.
Trump, of course, even tweeting on Sunday
night, quote, The United States of America
will be designating and TFA as a terrorist
organization.
We already talked on Monday about the legal
reality and constitutionality of Trump doing
that.
I don't want to rehash that today, but it
actually doesn't matter because it was a political
tool which was followed up on on Monday with
Trump saying I may send the U.S. military
to states against governors wishes to further
repress the protesters who he is insisting
are overwhelmingly violent lawbreakers.
Now, if you believe the protesters are more
violent than they are, you are more likely
to support Trump's idea of sending in the
military.
If you believe that violent and TFA, which
again, there's no there's no real that identifies
more of a strategy and an umbrella term than
an organization.
If you believe violent and TFA is a predominant
factor at these protests, you're more likely
to look the other way at repression of protesters
by police.
Well, we now have documents from the Washington
FBI field office which say very clearly as
of 5:00 p.m., based on CHF canvasing open
source and social media partner engagement
and liaison, FBI, Washington Field Office
has no intelligence indicating involvement
or presence of an TIFA.
Now, I want to be really, really, really,
really clear here.
This is one location.
On one day it was claimed that an TIFA were
all over D.C..
The FBI found that they were not.
This doesn't mean that there was no a. for
presence anywhere.
Clearly, there was some presence of whatever
we are defining as an TIFA.
The issue with all of this is that and TFA
itself is, first of all, tiny.
And secondly, it's completely sparse in its
organization.
And I want to make really crystal clear before
I start getting the, you know, the e-mails
and the tweets and all of it.
I am not telling you that I am supportive
of NTFS tactics.
I'm not denying that people operating under
the general banner of antifa have done violence
in the past.
Of course they have.
I'm not aware of a. for ever killing anybody.
But there has been violence done by people
sort of purporting to be under the umbrella
of Antifa.
And I am against that.
The point is, number one, and TFA is more
of an idea and a strategy than it is an organization
where we can say the KKK was present here.
OK.
Well, that's much more defined group.
There is a leadership structure, there is
membership, there are meetings, blah, blah,
blah.
That is not the case within TFA.
And that's why this is all fundamentally a
distraction.
The port protests are mostly peaceful.
Have there been bad actors?
Of course there have.
Looters have looted while protesters have
protested.
The point is whether or not they subscribe
to the general umbrella term of an TFA.
It lacks all organization and it doesn't change
that.
The bad actors are incredibly small in number.
Whether the non peaceful protesters are or
aren't.
And TFA is actually irrelevant here because
an TFA is not an organization with an established
structure, leadership or the like.
It's a way to justify using force against
protesters.
It's a way to justify Trump sending in the
troops, literally.
And it's a way to disqualify the activism
concerns of the protesters Tuesday night.
We did a livestream looking at protests in.
I'm trying to think now.
Boston, New York City, Denver, DC, Atlanta,
Los Angeles, Columbus, Ohio.
There were a couple other places I don't remember
exactly.
There was no violence anywhere during the
two hour stream where we were just watching
protests and all of these places, with the
exception of about five minutes in Atlanta
where protesters destroyed, you know, those
chain link fence is that go around a construction
site.
Some of that fencing was destroyed and there
were even claims that the reason that happened
is because police were releasing tear gas
and protesters had to in order to get away
from it, rip down some of that fencing.
That may be true or not.
Doesn't make it okay.
But the point is, we had to spend two hours
to find five minutes across eight or ten cities
of something that was short of peaceful protesting.
The reason this is being done is that Trump
can't lead any other way.
I told you on Monday, Tuesday he doesn't have
any other tools other than criticize the people
getting the media attention and think about
how can you deploy more shows of force later
in the program.
I'm going to talk to you about Donald Trump,
again, obsessed with Tank starting to ask
the Pentagon questions about what sort of
tanks could we deploy as a show of force along
with the military.
Pentagon appears to be turning against Trump.
Trump's former secretary of defense, Jim Mattis,
denouncing Trump.
And we're going to get to all of that later.
These are really fluid dynamics in terms of
the relationships between institutions of
power, where even the Pentagon and Department
of Defense, not organizations that I find
to be the epitome of altruism, not organizations
where I say you can always trust the Department
of Defense.
Even they are saying what Trump wants is too
much.
Remember to follow me on Twitter at David
Pakman.
And a quick reminder, if you regularly just
consume a clip here or there on IGT, vier
YouTube or Facebook.
We have a daily audio podcast, and I know
a lot of you prefer audio podcasts, long form.
A short video clips.
We have a free audio podcast.
You can find on iTunes, Stitcher, Spotify,
Google Play, podcasts, etc.
Make sure you're subscribe to that for The
Daily Show.
Let me know what you think about the latest
with the protests on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we'll be right back.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.